should say good afternoon
so dear translation could you say
something
it's already in english it is already
english because okay let's test
[Music]
um
traps
[Music]
thank you very much for your presence
and before it's yeah
yes thank you so much uh dear antonio
it's so good to be here and thank you
very much for your hospitality for the
friendship for the excellent cooperation
we have already a very strong working
relationship
and it's wonderful to have friends and
experts at the same time in the
presidency
because these are really challenging
times and
the portuguese presidency couldn't come
at a more decisive time
for europe indeed europe is going
through
very difficult times in many
member states we know that the situation
is very serious
what the covet pandemic is concerned
following the holiday break we see that
cases are spiking
and we see that new variants of the
virus have been found in several dozen
countries and restrictions which are
absolutely necessary
are definitely taking a hard
toll on people it is imperative
that we continue our efforts to keep
safe to protect ourselves and to protect
others but it's hard we are all in this
here together and we really have to
overcome
this pandemic together the european
union will support the member states in
all possible ways over the next
month we will need to focus on
major priorities and of course one of
the first priorities
is vaccination vaccination
is the light at the end of the tunnel of
this
pandemic at this difficult situation the
european commission has been working
tirelessly to secure enough doses of the
most promising vaccines
and indeed with the two first vaccines
on the market that is biontech
and moderna we have access to enough
doses
of vaccine to vaccinate over
80 percent of the european population
at the beginning of this week
astrazeneca
the third vaccine company has applied to
the european
medicines agency to get its vaccine
approved
and this would be with the third vaccine
that is authorized for europe a
situation where with all these three
vaccines we would have
one billion doses of vaccine available
now for us it's important that we
manage now the situation of the delivery
of the vaccines
and i got like many of you the
news today that pfizer announced
delays i immediately called the ceo
of pfizer and he explained
that there is a production delay in the
next weeks
but he reassured me that all guaranteed
doses
of the first quarter will be delivered
in the first quarter
he's personally on the case on reducing
the delay
period and to make sure that they will
catch
up as soon as possible that was
very important to convey the message to
him that we urgently
need the guaranteed doses within the
first quarter
besides that we have to remain vigilant
and we're not out of the woods at all
yet
als although having the vaccines because
the new variants
we discovered recently are concerning
as they increase the spread the speed of
the spread of the virus
and therefore we urgently need to
increase
our sequencing capacities in the
european union
this is the only possibility to not only
detect
variants of the virus but to react
swiftly to them a second priority of
course is as you mentioned
the economic recovery and i call on all
member states to swiftly ratify
the much needed recovery package next
generation eu
here i know that i can count on the
leadership
of the portuguese presidency and we will
work
very closely with the member states to
finalize their national
recovery and resilience plans our aim is
that the money from next generation eu
starts flowing to our people and to our
companies that
definitely needed now before the end
of the portuguese presidency it's very
encouraging to know
that we have with portugal a strong
partner
at our side to make this happen
and i also want to thank you antonio
for expressing your support
for three central priorities of this
commission
as you've just said it is the european
green deal
it is the digital decade in europe that
we are
beginning but as crucial as these two
priorities are
is the social demand dimension of the
recovery
europe is about people europe is about
the workers and the small businesses
it's about opportunities for young
people to find employment
the young generation that needs
perspectives it's about solidarity
in times of crisis and therefore i very
much
welcome the plans of the portuguese
presidency
and their commitment to strengthening
our european social market economy
the social summit in porto in may will
send a
very strong signal the european union
stands for recovery that
indeed leaves no one behind
and i very much welcome that this social
summit includes
civil society includes our social
partners
it's together with them that we will
make sure that the social market economy
is as lively and as
vibrant as it has been before the crisis
also after the crisis
finally throughout its history
portugal has given
if i may quote new worlds to the world
this is a quote from the famous poet
luis de gamos
and we dare antonio share the same goal
of a stronger europe
in the world this will be a crucial
period this portuguese presidency
to revive the transatlantic partnership
you mentioned it
to further develop our relationship with
africa
and indeed to deepen our ties with india
i very much look forward to the eu
india summit that will take place in
portugal in may
global europe will benefit a lot
from the portuguese presidency last but
not least
antonio your experience
your dedication will be invaluable
in this coming period and i wish the
portuguese presidency
great success and i am very much looking
forward to the common cooperation in
this presidency thank you
so much
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes thank you i very much uh welcome
the initiative of the greek prime
minister
what the vaccination certificate a
vaccination certificate is concerned
first of all plain and simply it is
absolutely necessary if you have been
vaccinated to have a certificate this is
a medical necessity
therefore this is the right way to go
forward
of course it has to be mutually
recognized
it's a wh o requirement so in that
we are very clear a second question is
um and this is a political and a legal
decision
what you allow to do with this
certificate
and i think this is something that we
will certainly discuss on a common
european level to have common
rules but um i think it's also indeed
important always to find the right
balance
for example you can always combine
either a certificate
or a negative coveted test if you did
not have access to a vaccination so far
so there are possibilities to find a
fair and equal balance
to those who have the certificate
already the vaccination and those who
didn't have access so far
okay
the
[Music]
is
i think the next question comes from
brussels
yes hi it's megan winter with the german
news agency
um thanks for the floor i've got a
question for the president
um concerning the late pfizer
supply do you have any more details on
that
how many doses did you expect for
february
how many doses will be delivered in
february
and how many doses will be delivered in
the first
quarter of the year thanks a lot
so these are all of course a question
that the
pfizer company has to answer i think it
is very important that
immediately we made clear that there is
a guarantee of a amount of doses that
have to be delivered in the first
quarter
so um it was good to talk to the ceo
a little while ago and he confirmed
and reassured me that they know um that
they have guaranteed these doses and
they
they will deliver these doses i think it
is good that
they are aware that for us it is a very
difficult situation because
as uh the prime minister just rightly
said
the first shots have been given and in a
certain amount of time
after four weeks the second shot has to
be given with biontech pfizer so
there's also a medical necessity and
need to stick to what we have agreed
to the schedule we have agreed and to do
the delivery therefore it is very good
that the ceo
uh him personally has said that he will
immediately turn his attention to
this question and we'll do everything
that is possible for him
to reduce uh the time of delay and
to bring further uh forward the time of
catching up
and again as i said he reassured that
during the first quarter the guaranteed
doses will be delivered
[Music]
in this respect i think it shows that
how important how important it was it
has been
that we from the very beginning
supported uh the pharmaceutical company
uh with our um advanced purchase
agreements to invest
in building up their scaling up their
production capacities
and we do the same right now still
with the
[Music]
pharmaceutical companies that they are
being supported in
many different ways to increase their
production
so i think there's a very clear case
that us in europe we have been
supportive and we will be supportive
what
scaling up of the production capacity is
concerned but we expect then that the
delivery schedule
is being fulfilled
uh hello can you hear me yeah yes
so i have another question from mrs on
the line and still on the same subject
uh six eu member countries uh have
expressed their their concerns
with regards to the the delays in the
divisor
uh delivery and uh expressing that the
fear that the
the this would undermine the credibility
process
of the vaccination process uh do you
agree what is your answer to these
countries
so first of all um it has been a
big success that as 27 we have
negotiated but
because otherwise we would never ever
have had access
as early and with such a large number
of doses it was the right way and is the
right way to go together as europeans
second of course this is not the first
time
that we see a delay in this process we
should not forget
that normally it takes 10 years to
develop a vaccine and to deliver it
now we have reduced this time to less
than a year
and we are facing all the difficulties
you normally face in an extended period
of time
it is not the first time that the
company announces that
it has for a short period of time
problems with delivery
and it's not only biotech files but
others too others had to delay for
example their application
time at the european medicine agency so
we'll have encountered these problems
before and we will encounter
these problems in this process but we
should not forget the
overall process is a big success we have
access
to overall 2.3
billion doses of vaccines so it is
enough for the whole european population
and our neighborhood this is so
important for us
that we do not only care for ourselves
but also for our
neighborhood be it the eastern the
western or the southern
neighborhood and indeed we have always
said
that the large numbers will kick in as
of
april when more companies are delivering
biotech pfizer was very fast that is
good that is an advantage
it's good that modena is on the mark
market now too
astrazeneca just has applied we expect
the authorization till the end of the
month and then we
expect that a delivery can start to
we expect still johnson johnson pretty
soon
so it shows that the broad portfolio
has mitigated the risks of the problems
that
always occur when you have these
processes at that speed
uh
for you just a question because you were
talking about the money flowing to to
the countries related to the
recovery plans before the end of the
presidency but i would like to
understand
when do you expect the ratification
process to be concluded
when do you expect to go to the markets
because according to the forest
foreign affairs minister the portuguese
minister it
might be possible uh in the in the
beginning of april is this
the date that you are working for
working with
uh uh
clarification please
next generation eu is concerned um
indeed good that we have it
um and the ratification process the
national ratification processes have to
go as
swiftly and as fast as possible so
um i'm calling on all member states to
follow up as rapidly as possible on this
national ratification and indeed the
moment we have the national ratification
we can go to the market and raise the
necessary capital on the market
it will be very interesting to raise
this capital through green bonds through
social bonds
an important topic for us
the reason why i have been calling on
the member states to deliver draft
national recovery plans as soon as
possible
is that we have to work on these plans
so in an optimal situation
the moment the national ratification has
taken place
and we are on the market raising capital
we are able to disperse
the first money to the different member
states who have
fulfilled all the criteria in their
national um
recovery and resilience plans
objective
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
completely
the translator cannot hear your question
okay
and
so um to your first question
we are in this together and the unity of
the european union
paid off throughout the whole crisis in
every field
where the crisis the pandemic challenged
us
we saw that national
uh lonely moves did not bear any fruits
were not successful at all but when we
went together
as 27 as one union we could overcome the
problems
and we were more successful and stronger
um than it
otherwise would have been possible so we
are in this
together and therefore the
uh the vaccination topic shows
that indeed it is for us of utmost
importance now
also to keep the unity
in the process of applying the vaccines
over time and therefore i think it pays
off also
just to overcome all the problems
together we have
for every single step that we do a
so-called steering board where all 27
member states are represented
in other words we take the daily or
every two day decisions that are
necessary
in screening this process always
together
and it paid off every member state has
strongs and weaknesses and if you
combine that
together you can overcome the problems
that are out there therefore this
process
has has been successful and we will keep
on going like that
what your question is concerned in
so-called potential
parallel negotiation the situation is
very clear
we have a very clear legal basis
an agreement as 27 a legal basis that
says
no parallel negotiations no parallel
contracts
because we just did not want to disturb
the negotiating powers
of 450 million europeans
and indeed it's also the the vice versa
situation is clear the pharmaceutical
companies
where the whole world is asking for the
product
also do not want to fragment the field
but they prefer of course to deal with
one of the largest demanders
in one entity and these are the 450
million europeans
what the fiscal rules are concerned
i think at the moment being we are in a
stage where we
have to make very clear that the support
that is given to the members that the
fiscal support should be
ongoing um for example the general
escape clause will of course stay
in place in 2021 and i was
always an advocate to say listen let's
not put in
timelines or deadlines but conditions
the situation has to improve then we can
work on changing or altering the system
but at the moment being we are amidst
the severe crisis a health crisis and an
economic crisis
and therefore no change at the moment
being
my relatives
is
[Music]
that thank you
[Music]
you